♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden met today
with members
of his administration
to discuss lowering
consumer prices
and also making sure both teams
get the ball in overtime.
A federal judge in Texas
ruled on Friday
that President Biden could not
require federal workers
to receive
the coronavirus vaccine.
Wow, nobody's letting Biden
get anything done.
At this point,
I wouldn't be surprised if
Wordle was only giving him
two rows.
[ Laughter ]
After the voting rights bills
failed to pass last week,
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki
advised people who are upset
to go to a kickboxing class
or have a margarita,
because what better way to save
democracy than with fun ideas
for first dates?
They're stripping away
our rights one by one.
Let's paint mugs.
[ Light laughter ]
According to a new report,
Britain's Prince Andrew
had a collection of more than
70 teddy bears and staff members
were ordered to arrange them,
according to a diagram.
And then they could get to work
on his enormous collection
of giant red flags.
The NFL reportedly notified
unvaccinated players last week
that they will no longer
be required
to be tested daily
for the coronavirus,
in fact, some of them
don't even have to come to work.
A television reporter
in West Virginia
who was hit by a car during
a live broadcast last week
got up uninjured and said quote,
"That's live TV for you."
Okay, as someone who's done a
lot of live TV, no, it's not!
[ Laughter ]
Ashlee Simpson lip syncing,
that's live TV for you.
You got hit by a car!
"Oh my God,
should we exchange info?"
"No, no, it's fine.
This is live TV."
Rapper Jay-Z has reportedly
signed onto a letter
urging New York Governor
Kathy Hochul and state lawmakers
to ban prosecutors
from using rap lyrics
as evidence against
defendants in court.
Not because it's unfair
just because it's so cringe-y
to hear lawyers recite them.
[ Laughter ]
Singer Adele last week
postponed her Las Vegas
residency less than 24 hours
before the first show.
Fortunately, Adele fans
are well equipped
to deal
with sudden heartbreak.
And finally, according to
the latest numbers,
New Yorkers place more than
600 million dollars
in bets during the first week
of mobile sports gambling,
all against the Knicks.
President Biden was caught
on a hot microphone yesterday,
referring to Fox News
reporter Peter Doocy as,
"a stupid son of a bitch."
Said Biden, "I am so sorry
that was supposed to be
into the main mic."
[ Laughter ]
After he was caught referring
to Fox News reporter Peter Doocy
as, "a stupid son of a bitch."
President Biden reportedly
called Doocy to clear the air.
And just like Biden
being elected,
Doocy is going to pretend
it never happened.
And to me, the crazy part of all
this isn't that Biden got mad.
The Doocy tried
to make him look bad.
It's that Biden was so surprised
that Doocy tried
to make him look bad.
Where are you, Ben, dude?
That's the game.
Biden was like that kid
in fourth grade
who wanted to play dodgeball
and then got super mad
that someone whipped
a ball at him.
[ Laughter ]
As tensions increase between
the U.S. and Russia,
White House
Press Secretary Jen Psaki
warned yesterday that
American citizens in Ukraine
should leave the country now,
but added that no organized
evacuation is planned.
Why is that? Because of the last
one you organized?
[ Audience "Ohs" ]
"We'd love to help out."
"We're good."
"Just going to go on
Expedia, thank you."
Yesterday marked
the start of tax season
for those who celebrate.
NASA announced yesterday
that the world's largest
and most powerful
space telescope
has reached
its observation post
and is now one million miles
away from Earth -- Must be nice.
[ Laughter ]
Hilton announced yesterday
that its Homewood Suites
chain of hotels
is now 100 percent pet friendly,
while days in announcing
they have enough animals
to worry about.
It's nice to see two raccoons
and a snake getting along.
Chris-- it's an uneasy peace.
Krispy Kreme will offer
a dozen free donuts
to anyone who donates blood
amid a national shortage.
Tough break for anyone
who drank it already.
Guys are out a dozen donuts.
Finally, a couple in India
recently announced
that they will have
their wedding in the metaverse
and have invited
two thousand people.
It's the perfect way to say
"We don't want
our grandparents to come."
"It's in the what?"
Supreme Court Justice
Stephen Breyer
is reportedly planning to retire
at the end of the current term,
which would allow President
Biden to appoint a successor.
Said Mitch McConnell, with only
three years left in his term,
"I don't think so."
President Biden visited
an ice cream store
yesterday in Washington, D.C.
and reportedly got
a scoop of chocolate
with peanut butter flecks
and a scoop of black
out chocolate cake.
So, yeah, he's seen
the approval numbers.
[ As Biden ] I'm going to need
a second scoop.
[ Normal voice ] President Biden
met today with the CEOs of Ford,
General Motors,
and several other companies
to discuss his
"Build Back Better" agenda.
But of course,
it quickly devolved into Biden
pitching car names.
[ As Biden ]
So what about the Ford Shark?
That's a pretty good
name the Ford Shark.
[ Normal voice ] President Biden
told reporters yesterday
that a potential
Russian invasion of Ukraine
would likely be
the quote largest invasion
since World War Two.
So I guess he's never been
to a target on Black Friday.
[ Laughter ]
In a video posted
on social media today,
former President Trump
told a golfing partner
that he would be the 45th
and 47th president
of the United States.
Then again, it wouldn't be
the first time
he lied to a golf partner.
[ As Trump ]
Put me down for four.
Yeah, it's a four. It's a four.
[ Normal voice ] After Vermont
Senator Bernie Sanders
suggested that he would support
a primary challenger
against Democratic
Senator Joe Manchin,
Manchin said yesterday, "Senator
Sanders is not a Democrat."
Said Sanders, "Thank you."
Organizers of next month's
Winter Olympics in Beijing
announced they will provide
free condoms to athletes,
and I'm pretty excited
to find out what that event is.
[ Laughter ]
It seems weird
it's in the winter.
Amazon endorsed the bill
in Congress yesterday
that would legalize marijuana
on a federal level.
Oh, really?
Does Amazon support something
that would make it even harder
for people to go out to a store?
[ Laughter ]
"Alexa order Doritos.
Yes, make weekly."
[ Light laughter ]
And finally, musician Kid Rock
released a song
this week that criticizes
coronavirus restrictions.
Oh, buddy,
that's not why people
are staying
six feet away from you.
President Biden said today
that he is planning
to name his nominee
to replace retiring Supreme
Court Justice Stephen Breyer
by the end of next month
and then a day or two
after that,
he'll nickname the nominee.
[ As Biden ]
Hey, Super Judge! Judge-a-reno!
I'll get one, don't worry.
After White House press
secretary Jen Psaki
said yesterday that President
Biden will stand by his
commitment to appoint a black
woman to the Supreme Court.
A Fox News panel criticized
the administration's
selection process.
I'll take a wild guess
and say they have exactly
two problems with a black woman.
The pharmaceutical company
Moderna announced yesterday
that it has begun testing
its Omicron-specific
coronavirus vaccine feels like
that might be outdated
by the time it's ready.
That's like hearing that
Apple's working on an iPhone 7.
According to the latest numbers,
the U.S. economy last quarter
grew by 6.9%.
"My pleasure," said Spider-Man.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
a witness told
federal prosecutors
that he was present
when Republican Congressman
Matt Gaetz was told
that he had sex with a minor,
and he said you could
have heard a pin drop
at that homecoming dance.
And almost in here.
In honor of the park's
30th anniversary
and Women's History Month
in March,
Disneyland Paris
announced yesterday
that Minnie Mouse
will wear a dark blue
and black polka dotted pantsuit
designed by Stella McCartney.
Unfortunately, that still won't
make up for the fact
that you brought
your wife to Paris
and then took her
to Disneyland.
Hey, you see the pantsuit.
A representative of
the anti-drug group
D.A.R.E. criticize the HBO show
"Euphoria," in a new interview,
and said it glorifies narcotics
use among high school students.
But realistically,
how many teens can afford
HBO and narcotics?
[ Laughter ]
McDonald's is set to begin
selling a new item
consisting of a chicken
sandwich, Big Mac,
and Filet-O-Fish,
all in one bun called
Land, Air, and Sea,
as opposed to its original name
Bathroom Hospital Cemetery.
And a different way.
And finally, the Navy announced
yesterday
that it has discharged
45 sailors
for refusing to get
the coronavirus vaccine.
Wow, I didn't realize the virus
could be transmitted
through seamen.
Discharged, discharged seamen.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the show
for the whole night.